I think that's being very intentional
about how you spend your time so there's
a minimal amount of time in the day we
all have the same number of minut
minutes and hours okay so if you let's
just take writing a book since that's on
my head um this is the hardest thing
that I'm going to do all day long so I'm
going to choose a certain the hours when
I'm most awake when I'm most uh my brain
is really humming this is the morning
hours and then I'm going to protect
those hours and every day whether I feel
like it or not I'm going to get to my
desk and I'm going to start writing and
I'm going to do that every morning for a
year until that book is written and so
it's saying I'm not going to let my
inbox uh my phone messages my emails get
in the way of that thing that I'm
committed to the most important part of
my day and then I'm going to leave these
other things that are timec consuming
annoying all that other stuff but it's
less of a priority and I'm going to put
them later in the day so I think to
answer your question it is being very
intentional about how you focus us your
attention in your day as a leader and as
a staff person at any
[Music]
level Michelle Rigby Assad welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
being here with me how are you I'm doing
great thanks for having me Michael thank
you very much for for your presence and
for taking the time to to join me here
so Michelle um you're you have a book
coming out and in just about well eight
days from today's uh recording on
January 14th conquering obstacles and
achieving your life's Mission H and I
was particularly intrigued to to speak
with you because I'm really curious
about this notion of getting things done
but getting the right things done and uh
and a lot of that is about moving
forward and moving forward also in the
right direction and right before we
started uh this recording you shared a
really interesting story that that I
think will get us right into the right
into the mix so so please go ahead
Michelle yeah absolutely so um my new
book called get off the x is about
getting out of your personal and
professional Comfort zones and uh
obviously being willing to do hard
things and being willing to go where
other people won't go and um as part of
that I've learned in my own life that
the most meaningful things are the
hardest so here I was in um during the
10 years of my intelligence career in
the CIA I spent a torn bag debt during
the hardest part of the war and as you
can imagine we're trying to just stop
the next terror attack from happening so
you're you're running with your hair on
fire all day long you're exhausted
because you're just trying to manage all
of the intelligen that's coming in
package it appropriately and then get it
out to the warf fighter or the National
Security Council of the White House and
so you're just you're working holidays
you're working weekends you're working
you know 16 hours a day it's
exhausting and it was M it was probably
three or four months into that one-year
tour where I suddenly realized that this
Source was lying to us for like a year
or a year and a half and so we had spent
all this time all this energy running a
source which by the way is not an easy
thing to do in a war zone very dangerous
and he'd been fabricating information
and selling it to us as intelligence and
I thought to myself oh no because now I
have seen what a fabricator looks like
and I'm realizing that we are likely
running multiple Fabricators and liars
and then I just realized my gosh we're
working so hard but we're focused on the
wrong things so I had to take this extra
energy this take a step back and say
okay I can't do this anymore because
every time I put out bad intelligence
and our brothers and sisters roll off a
military base to action that intel if
it's bad then I'll tell you what it's on
me when they get injured or they get
killed or they get blown up in the
process so I have to take a step back
and be strategic and say is this Source
really who he says he is is he really a
a terrorist leader is he giving us good
stuff or not and it was a real uh
changing point in my life because I
realized my God I spend a lot of my time
running in the wrong direction running
hard running with all my energy and I'm
not getting anywhere and so how often do
we do that in our
lives right yeah I mean I think this is
a probably probably a question that that
we that should be asked more frequently
but probably is not asked enough I'm
curious how how you know this question
of am I am I doing the right thing am I
running after the right thing am I how
do I know what is the right thing to be
running after how was was this the
turning point for you to start asking
that question and to start
uncovering the the different ways of
thinking about this yeah absolutely so
that was the launch point for me to say
okay I have a lot of tools at my
disposal working for the CIA in this war
zone so I'm not going to take what the
sources give me as gospel I'm going to
question everything and then I'm going
to see what are the results of that
Intel collection I'm going to contact
the military and I'm going to say when
we told you the car bomb was at X
location did you find the car bomb or I
was told the missiles were located in
this orchard west of Baghdad did you go
to the Orchard and find the missiles or
not
and so I know it sounds really
straightforward and easy but when you're
exhausted when you have a to-do list
that's like a mile long and you can just
barely get through the minimum every day
you don't have the extra mental capacity
to be strategic but I realized like I
have to this is a matter of life and
death and so once I actually started
asking those hard questions and then
also testing our sources you know
actually really um there's a a bunch of
clever things you can do in intelligence
to test a source to see if they're
telling you the truth after all that I
realized oh my God We've been wasting
time on lying sources a lot of them too
many of them how does this fit into our
daily lives if you will so you're you're
obviously you know sharing an example
from your from your time at the CIA and
and as an engine in the field where
there's clear uncertainty around
sources from my time in my military
I I I know that quite well as well but
how does this impact us in our daily
lives this question of verif you know
the vi the verification of do we know
what we're really up against and the the
Integrity of the information that we
have so I I think that's being very
intentional about how you spend your
time so there's a minimal amount of time
in the day we all have the same number
of minut minutes and hours okay so if
you let's just take writing a book since
that's on my head um this is the hardest
thing that I'm going to do all day long
so I'm going to choose a certain the
hours when I'm most awake when I'm most
uh my brain is really humming this is
the morning hours and then I'm going to
protect those hours and every day
whether I feel like it or not I'm going
to get to my desk and I'm going to start
writing and I'm going to do that every
morning for a year until that book is
written and so it's saying I'm not GNA
let my inbox uh my phone messages my
emails get in the way of that thing that
I'm committed to the most important part
of my day and then I'm going to leave
these other things that are time
consuming annoying all that other stuff
but it's less of a priority and I'm
going to put them later in the day so I
think to answer your question it is
being very intentional about how you
focus your attention in your day as a
leader and as a staff person at any
level and is it is it mainly about
focusing the intention or is it also
being able to look at this the task
itself but in a different light question
everything yes question everything is
this getting me where I need to go like
you have a process in place at a company
and you've been doing this process for
years and years and years as long as you
can remember you have to stop and say
what's the point of this are we even is
this getting us anywhere is this moving
the needle so really it is questioning
the way you hire the way you train the
way you uh put people into the right
position
you know the way you design products the
way you Market it is questioning
everything and not doing things just
because that's the way you've always
done them I I guess there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of logic to it I try to do
that a lot of my day-to-day as well but
there's a lot of times where I also stop
myself and think well am I you know am I
really questioning everything am I
really open to uncovering things that I
may be doing or have been doing which
are wrong or may not be as productive or
conducive for where I want to get to and
it's a scary thing to do it's a scary
sub it's a scary action to deal with
because dealing with reality sometimes
even if it's the right thing it's not
always it's not always a easy especially
when reality has hard truths to it oh
this is so true and then you you look at
what's happening in our culture now
we've got like the Elon musks of the
world that man is so good at questioning
everything I love his mindset like why
are you doing that why are we spending
billions of dollar dollars developing
the F-35 when the future is in uh uh
other types of crafts cheaper crafts
unmanned aerial Vehicles you know so
he's asking these really big questions
and it's really I think going to um help
people be more creative about the
questions they ask and have the courage
because like you just said like it's
hard to say to your company guys
spending half of our day doing the wrong
stuff it really is
hard how do you find people can adapt
easiest to this to this notion of oh I'm
doing the wrong thing right now or I'm
not I'm not or I've been doing the wrong
thing for the last while and now I need
to recalibrate because it it takes an
ego check to to deal with that question
right because these this thing would be
to to push forward yeah so I think it
can be I mean especially if you got
leadership that is entrenched in the old
ways of doing things and you're a
creative person and you see a better way
it's like the most frustrating place to
be here's what I found I will Implement
my new idea in small ways in the ways
that I can within the structure that I'm
in and my results will speak for me so I
do what I can and then I show my results
to the world so you're not preaching at
them you're showing them the evidence of
doing things differently and that might
be the thing that cracks things open in
your company sometimes you got to start
small before you do the big stuff so so
for you it's about taking baby steps to
start small start cracking it and then
and then and then be able to take the
bigger piece I was also as you were
saying that I was thinking to myself
about this notion of you know a lot of
the episodes in this in this show are
about startups and about product finding
product Market fit it's one of the you
know what as as we're talking about this
of of doing the right things and
focusing and prioritizing for Founders
one of the hardest things to do is to
find product Market fit we we we really
believe in this paino we really believe
in a problem and then we go after it and
sometimes we too quickly go after
building a solution without validating
enough that the sources that we have
that tell us this is a problem really
are the right sources and sometimes
people are lying to us without even
knowing that they're lying to us and and
so and then when you have to Pivot
that's a really hard thing to do because
you've raised money from investors you
have employees you have maybe design
Partners who think they want your
solution and maybe they do but maybe
they're not representative of the market
and then as a Founder you sit back and
you think to yourself like wow okay I I
I need to change I guess what I need to
do but I don't even know how to start
and so for me there's a lot of analogies
to what you're describing in the context
of maybe individuals but also in the
context of a whole organization like the
way a startup behaves and needs to
decide what to do yeah I think the
hardest thing when you're doing a
startup or you've got a new product is
you're like you said you're vetting
you're vetting the audience you're
vetting the consumer you're trying to
understand how to place things um and I
think we're so quick to say well I've
asked a few questions I vetted it when I
you know I think you're implying and I
totally agree with you I'm like the
queen of vetting intelligence
information like you can never ask too
many
questions really you can never ask too
many questions no and and don't stop
asking questions and then if you do go
down the wrong road boy it's better to
make that correction now than to get
further down that road like okay so
there's been some money lost but you've
realized you you need a tweak again it's
scary it's sometime embarrassing you're
like ah I missed this um but I think you
can't build a company without the
humility of making Corrections along the
way how do you do you find is is is
potentially helpful or or effective to
build a mindset around this so that it
translates into the really core daytoday
of who we are so we we started this
conversation with you saying you know
question everything and it sound and and
it would be very tiring to question
everything if you're not adapted to it
from your brain and from your mind so
how do you develop a mindset and a
narrative where you can question
everything and do that in a really
healthy way well I think it's about
being curious um so for me like I was so
fascinated by what makes a terrorist
what makes them tick uh what's the
psychology of terrorism you know how do
you become the leader of a terror cell
so for me asking the questions to vet
The Source was a fascinating process
like um so I'm vetting him but I'm also
learning in the process about where did
this guy come from and what's his family
like and what kind of ideology has been
fed into him by whom and and so what
drove that was more than anything my
curiosity to learn always learning oh
you know and then what is so fascinating
is after you've had enough of those
experiences where you're having those um
difficult I wouldn't say difficult
conversations they're only difficult if
someone's lying suddenly if someone's
not telling you the truth and they're
not a terror cell leader then it's going
to become difficult and you can't get
your questions answered right they they
deflect they push back they get upset
like there's all these things Liars do
when they're not telling you the truth
but that sense of curiosity allow that
to drive your approach to
operations um and so that's how in the
long run I became an expert at vetting
and Counter Intelligence I dealt with so
many fake and lying sources that I know
when the real guy shows up and walks
through the door he's a legit
terrorist it's so fascinating you know
that that guy walks through the door and
he's all of himself and arrogant and
prideful and I'm like that's exactly how
a terrorist acts and then the guy walks
through the door and he's got a limp
handshake and he's shaking and he's he's
a very small not not small as in small
stature man but small personality and I
think I don't think you're a terrorist
so it's so fascinating that entire
process of vetting and how much you
learn along the way
absolutely now tell me Michelle
the we talked a lot about how to
get out of our comfort zone and how to
think differently about about and
questioning and and and how to get into
the mindset but I I feel like we almost
skipped this question of why do we need
to do that right and I don't think I
don't think it's just for um saving time
from running after the wrong wrong
information from a lying Source it's not
just about the time it's it's all it
goes I think it's bigger than that why
so what is a big motivation in your eyes
to to be doing this type of work and to
get into this type of mindset yeah so so
for me this concept of get off the X
which we use in law enforcement and the
military and intelligence to help us
learn how to survive an ambush or
terrorist attack so the x is literally
uh the location of that attack against
you of the ambush in order to survive
the attack or have the best chances for
survival you've got to move off that X
so that's why we say get off the and
that's the name of the book but and I
just realized like I know so many people
who are on this crazy comfort zone X of
their life where you've just gotten into
this rhythm of doing the same thing
every day because it's easy right we're
human beings and we're wired
intrinsically to be efficient and that
efficiency keeps us wetted to processes
and objectives that are e they're just
simple um and
straightforward so for me if you want to
have meaning in your life you have to be
strategic about pushing through the
comfort zone into something that scares
you like I always say if you're not a
little bit scared you're not trying hard
enough um and so for me what's on the
other side of that pain of that pushing
through is incredible purpose and and I
think without purpose we human beings we
fall apart like we actually need that
and I see that in and my friends and
family around me who don't have a lot of
purpose they're withering and so it
turns out that we shouldn't run from the
pain we should embrace that because
that's where how we're actually put
together as human beings I love it so
embracing the pain that that's I I love
the the context of how looking at pain
and and being scared as a signal and as
a testament to whether we're doing the
real work before we end this uh this
really fun discussion
um how do you want to leave us Michelle
in a way that anybody listening here can
be left H inspired or or action oriented
in this space so what what is something
that potentially even you know anybody
that's listening here can do right after
listening to this that would drive us
towards having this mindset yeah it's a
really simple but
profoundly uh transformative approach
which is we all get stuck
we get big stuck we get little stuck
like how do I get this project done or
what do I do with my life so these are
very different uh conditions of being
stuck but we're all stuck in some manner
every day and so I always say to myself
okay Michelle here's your goal you're
working towards today what can I do
right now today to push that thing
forward it doesn't mean what can I do
that will be successful in pushing me
forward no not the perfect thing
anything and so it takes that weight of
like oh my God I have to to find the
perfect Next Step most of the time we
are successful simply because every day
we got up and said today what can I do
to get off the
X um no matter how simple no matter how
silly no matter how small it is those
cumulative cumulative steps or what
makes a difference really I love it
Michelle thank you so much for spending
this time with me I really enjoyed it I
really appreciate it wishing you best of
luck with the book launch and thank you
very much for being here awesome thank
thank you thank you